so I looked down and she had peed on me
all over me my name is Stephanie and I
substitute teach and I teach ESL I have
been teaching for three years hi my name
is Salani
I teach science and I've been teaching
for five years my name is Vanessa and
I've been a preschool teacher for over
12 years now today we're gonna talk
about teacher horror stories I got some
recently I was teaching a program for
students who come here from China you
teach the pronunciation and vocabulary
and help them with their English and at
the end we have a ceremony where some of
the students get to come up and talk
about their experience one of the
students got up there and he said this
speech is gonna be about
we all thought that's what he said
and looked at each other just like
what's going on but apparently he said
thanking this speech is about thanking
so it's really awkward moment I don't
think any of the students noticed
because they were kind of in the same
boat of learning English the other
teachers kind of like oh great great job
teaching teaching your students this
summer staff yes
so since I'm a science teacher I do a
lot of experiments to get the kids
engaged one of the experiments I did had
to do with digestion and I took giant
bowls of oatmeal with oil in it just to
kind of give the presence of like food
digesting in the stomach and I used
nylons that are really stretchy to
squeeze the oatmeal through to kind of
give the idea of like how intestines
work so it was working everything was
great the kids were having a blast and
then they were getting to the end of
squeezing it out they started to realize
what was happening that it's stimulating
like going to the bathroom one of the
kids was getting nauseous and they kept
saying I feel sick and I was like okay
well you know take a break outside and
then they came back in and then once
they were finished one of the students
just projectile vomited all over
everything in the table and another
student vomited because the other
student bobbitt it was such a mess it
was so disgusting
so after both students puked it was
total chaos everybody started screaming
kids were freaking out a couple of them
ran out of the classroom jumping
throwing their desks just over leagues
their behavior of course I mean I get it
it's throw-up and then the smell it just
ruined everybody because nobody wants to
smell oatmeal and then you have that
throw-up smell and I was right before
lunch so pretty much messed up the whole
day nobody wanted to eat I definitely
had to hold back I definitely had to
take a deep breath gather myself
together and try to stay calm for the
rest of the class because if I started
Wilin out then it would have been over
of course it was a natural reaction to
just a smell so nobody got in trouble
but definitely the talk of the town
definitely a lot of the teachers the
principal and there was some laugh some
giggles teachers coming to check a lot
of Febreze a lot of Febreze a lot of
kids now want to take my class they're
like I want to go to science class
because if it's that cool where they
throw up I want to go so it turned out
to be positive this was a first and
hopefully last situation first your
teaching I was an assistant I'm new in
the field trying to prove Who I am prove
my worth as a teacher and it's nap time
or it's just the end of naptime so the
kids are all started like starting to
wake up and sometimes they're a little
emotional when they wake up from their
little cots so I was helping this one
child that was crying I was kind of
patting his or her back I can't remember
and then another child comes to me kind
of crying as well since I was busy
helping this child that child just comes
and I'm squatting down so she sits on me
with you know facing me her legs around
me this way
so I'm consoling her also trying to help
this child here I didn't think anything
of it until I started feeling something
warm in this area I looked down I lift
her off of me and she had peed on me
full-on peed all over me so I just stand
up and I'm like oh my gosh okay go to
the bathroom but she had already
finished so there was no point as I
stood up I realized that it looked like
I had peed on myself the placement of it
was just perfect some of the children
were still sleeping so they didn't
really notice and my lead teacher was
kind of laughing at me it was like okay
you can go home like if it was a little
bar for me or something you know just
kind of clean it off but since it looked
like I had full-on peed on myself I got
to go home for the day but after that
day that little girl is my favorite she
totally marked her territory I think
it's just a funny
that I'll bring up every now and then
and it happens to other teachers at some
point even in the center that I met now
I've had a child sit on me after having
an accident so I got pee on my leg it's
just preschool is full of pee at this
point I just carry extra clothes in my
car like it is what it is like you just
have to be ready it's part of the job
[Music]
[Music]